good morning it's good to be with you
upon for studying today's text I was
struck by how ratcheted up they felt I
could feel my blood pressure rise we are
nearing the end of the church year and
the texts have a POC elliptic tone and
we are indeed anxious in our hearing yet
the words offer such comfort such
clarity of God's complete love for us
within the prediction of the destruction
of the temple if only we can endure the
mayhem if only we can endure the man a
few weeks back I hit a low point when a
student from one of our Christian groups
on campus came to me and said Sharon I
do not want to help other religious
groups to do their jobs better it would
seem disloyal to my own to the tenets of
my faith I'm uncomfortable with this
whole notion my heart sunk I thought how
do I get through to this student that
reaching out to someone so very
different than oneself is not a bad
thing it does not go against what god
has always asked of us and yet again it
appears to be the dealbreaker the
component of this holy interaction that
we are working so hard to cultivate that
stops everything cold for some context
the student came to me because of an
exercise that the inter-religious
Leadership Council had recently done
together during one of the regular
meetings the IRL see is compromise is
comprised interesting of the student
leaders of many of the different
religious groups on campus and they meet
every other week over supper to swap
notes about what it takes to lead a
group on campus and to take a stab at
getting to know a bit more about each
other as well as the multiple faith
traditions they represent their a
remarkable group of dedicated leaders
some from large religious organizations
with hundreds of members and others from
smaller groups who are just trying to
keep momentum going with modest
involvement I am continually learning
from them their perspective on the world
we live in on college life on their
spiritual journeys is astounding to me
they live in the midst of such pressure
such complexities there is constant
competition for their time their energy
and their spirit from the demands of
their intellectual pursuits and their
social engagements they take their
obligations seriously and they are
incredibly thoughtful participants
within this group which is why I was so
troubled by this students earlier
statement had we hit an impermeable
barrier was the hope for this simple
endeavor and illusion was I asking too
much of them the exercise was one in
which they were asked to talk together
in pairs about the ups and downs of
leading their respective groups the goal
was simply to exchange ideas and
strategies for sustainable leadership
for student religious organizations the
student who brought this concern to me
was extremely thoughtful and I knew it
took some real courage to come and talk
to me and honestly state how hard the
exercise was I admit I did feel at a
loss for the right words in response
sometimes the inter-religious encounter
takes us to the edges far away from
where we are comfortable and those edges
can be very sharp around this time last
year I had the opportunity to hear a
lecture by mohamed abu Nemer abu nemer
is a Palestinian from Israel and is an
academic and an authority on conflict
resolution particularly in the Middle
East he is also the director of the
peace building and development institute
in washington DC and has led countless
workshops on inter-religious engagement
in some of the most tension-filled parts
of the world he is a real straight
talker and does not sugarcoat the
reality of intergroup and specifically
inter-religious engagement he has seen
it all has experienced deep defeat and
despair along the way
a and yet he's kept at it during his
lecture he described for us one of the
most compellingly true ways to
understand this process that I have ever
heard he basically said that there are
two ways we tend to think about
interfaith dialogue and community
building the first is to imagine that
you're looking through a window at a
group of people in conversation from
different and often differing
perspectives from one another as you
look through this window you are
informed by their difference you hear
their perspectives and you draw
conclusions from it but still you are
not in it remember you are looking
through a window it appears orderly and
even inspiring this is where most of us
stand when it comes to encountering
difference we might seek out the window
be excited by its existence and
committed to regularly look through it
but that is it we do not see ourselves
in the room then there are those who
have decided to walk through the door
and as a believer would probably put it
be in the mess in the room of so many
differences are people who are in real
conflict with one another but they are
also in relationship with each other
they are trying to build on these
relationships and what they are learning
about each other's tradition brings them
more and more open to a point of
transformation because they are willing
to be in the room and by design by fate
they are there this relationship with
all the compromise and the promise can
mean so much it can be that
transformative experience this
experience often leads to greater
understanding and in some cases maybe
even a certain kind of love he has seen
this time and again in his work and he's
realistic that this transformation
cannot happen overnight he is road-weary
from the process humbled by its weight
but persistent that it is essential to
our existence I have seen it too and I
have spoken about it often when this
transformation happens on a college
campus it's wonderful and life-changing
when it happens in the world though
tougher to pull off it can be even more
fertile both Paul's letter and Luke's
Gospel invite us to vision our community
and the very work of our faith without
boundaries with that literal or
figurative walls these texts invite us
to imagine ourselves in a kind of
partnership with one another one where
we do not respond to violence or
corruption with more of the same they
are asking that we resist the temptation
to mimic the chaos around us considering
the world we live in now this feels
quite daunting at times even hopeless I
read a reflection recently on Luke's
text that has an interesting take on all
this it described apocalyptic thinking
as an anthropological category which
served one function up until the time of
Jesus in every other manifestation of
apocalyptic the violence experienced by
the community demands a violent response
but the community transfers their
violence on to God the reflection I read
had a strong caution as we allow God to
bear our violence for us we have then
created a God who sanctifies our own we
make ourselves warrior reflections of
our own projected violence we make up
holy armies to fight the wars of our
created god I was particularly stuck by
that last statement because it reveals a
hidden ugly truth within religious
communities that we still encounter we
make up holy armies to fight the wars of
our created God are created God
Jesus does not deny the reality of the
disillusion of human culture that
apocalyptic predicts he does however
separated from God as a source or a
violent solution this is an embrace of a
gospel that is more confident in god's
solution because it is not just a larger
vision of ours just this past thursday
had the privilege of convening a special
dinner meeting with some yale world
fellows and again the members of the
inter-religious leadership council the
world fellows program was just finishing
its ninth year here at yale and it
brings together some of the most dynamic
emerging leaders from around the world
for a full semester the fellows interact
with Yale and the New Haven community
and their presence is electrifying
challenging inspiring and oftentimes
just plain I opening for many of us this
event last Thursday was no exception one
of the fellows who joined us was a young
woman from Lebanon and I invited her to
simply tell her story her name was
mayako she was a founding member of the
free Patriotic Movement advisor to a
former prime minister and current member
of parliament mahon and was raised just
outside of Beirut may spoke to us about
what it was like growing up with a
Jewish mother and a Greek Orthodox
father in Beirut her siblings aunts and
uncles cousins and friends were Jewish
Christian and Muslim she was very
matter-of-fact that she spoke offering
Frank accounts of what it was like to
live in the midst of such plurality of
faiths an obvious religious tension and
yet navigate with vinit in such a way as
to not feel alien from any one community
she grew up and was formed in the messy
room Abu Niebuhr was describing it was
all her community her blood when she
spoke about religious tensions around
the world she marveled at how
appeared to her that all the religious
communities seemed to think that God was
speaking only to them at a young age
because of how she grew up making to the
early conclusion that this was
impossible and that God's voice could
not be segregated by tradition rather
the traditions segregated God God was
theirs and no others this made no sense
to her and she concluded that it
probably made even less sense to God I
wondered what the student I mentioned
earlier might be thinking had we hit yet
another sharp edge it's so very tempting
to hide to retreat within one's own
religious community suspicious of others
protective of one's own I see it all the
time people fear that they are disloyal
to their beliefs or to the others in
their community if they are an
appreciative relationship with others
who live very different spiritual
realities to some the Christian call to
evangelize is understood to mean
something that might indeed end in
separation if one is not persuasive
enough it's not my intention to sound
harsh I'm trying to be anything but that
however i am trying to illustrate that i
think we are missing God's points I
suspect may is much closer to it in our
well-meaning attempts to be committed
people of faith we are often
misappropriating our own agency with God
we cannot create the God that picks us
just us over another God was here before
us God created us and as the psalmist
writes God will rule the world with
justice and the people's with fairness
our task is to stay out of God's Way we
must look from side to side be in messy
relationship with one another do our
work
and nurture this world we all share Joan
chidester tells us we must not be
seduced by externals even by the
splendors of religion nothing but God is
God and it is God we must seek not the
rituals nor the riches of the faithful
but only the depth of faith right now
the university church is in the process
of discerning its mission it is
committed to exploring together the
depth of faith this church this assembly
of strangers who are family in Christian
relationship is diligently trying to be
active in its own formation whether we
are packing lunches for chapel on the
green experimenting with a new
liturgical element supporting our
neighbors through cooking at Columbus
house or are engaging in deep
conversation with one another outside
these walls we are community and we are
trying to be open to what this means in
a university setting were considerable
demands of the norm in the midst of a
city that needs can overwhelm at a time
in history when we feel great distress
on numerous fronts as uncertain as these
times may feel to us the text for today
written centuries ago provide a much
needed and timeless lens into what we
must keep at the forefront of our
thinking we must endure the mayhem we
must not respond to chaos with more of
the same and again we are called to sing
a new song in a new way to our God who
has worked wonders the late john
o'donohue irish poet and teacher offers
a beautiful blessing for the start of a
new day so i'll close with it is a
loving hope for all of us who walk this
earth from many families of faith as
God's own beloved children and for those
of us here in this distinctly Christian
community as we look in anticipation
chin toward a new year somewhere out at
the edges the night is turning and the
waves of darkness begin to brighten the
shore of dawn the heavy dark falls back
to earth and the freed air goes wild
with light the heart fills with fresh
bright breath and foster to give birth
to color I arise today in the name of
silence womb of the word in the name of
stillness home of belonging in the name
of the solitude of the soul and the
earth I arise today blessed by all
things wings of breath delight of eyes
wonder of whisper intimacy of touch
eternity of soul urgency of thought
miracle of health embrace of God may I
live this day compassionate of heart
clear in word gracious and awareness
courageous in thought generous generous
in love amen